look at that Silver Fox so distinguished
so sophisticated Wow
but what if I told you that this guy was
a millennial it's true just barely
according to Joe he started going gray
when he was 16 by 22 he was pretty much
totally gray why does that happen and
why does hair turn gray in the first
place
[Music]
there's something about a silver fox if
you can pull it off when I got rid of my
gray hair I wanted a natural look but
many people hate the idea of going gray
there's an entire industry built around
fighting it it's like you took off ten
years in just five minutes just for men
she'll love the way you look so why does
it happen the process of hair changing
from darker color to white or gray with
age is mainly due to genetics it can be
inherited from either parent the color
of our hair is determined by the form of
hair pigment that we have the pigment is
actually produced along the hair shaft
and there are two main forms of hair
pigment there is eumelanin and
pheomelanin eumelanin is what we see in
brunettes and darker haired people and
pheomelanin is what we see in blondes
and redheads the cells in our hair bulb
produce a little bit of hydrogen
peroxide which is a metabolic by-product
and typically there's an enzyme called
catalase that breaks this down to water
in oxygen but as we age there's
declining levels of catalase and this
allows that buildup of hydrogen peroxide
and the hair bulb which damages and
destroys the melanocytes or the pigment
producing cells of our hair so I wanted
you to take a look at my colleague Joe
here Joe is technically a millennial he
started to go gray when he was 16 and by
22 it was pretty much gray all over what
happened to Joe so when individuals gray
early in life before the age of 20 is
called premature graying and
is due to genes and we know there's a
one gene in particular that's been
targeted called interferon regulatory
factor 4 which is important in
regulating and producing melanin in the
hair
Joe was lucky enough to inherit some
genes that predisposed him to developing
gray hair early in life obviously Joe
has gray hair on his head when you go
gray when your head does the hair on the
other parts of your body go gray as well
no no no Joe Joe Joe Joe we can picture
it so you can grow gray hair anywhere in
your body wherever you have hair the
hair is susceptible to oxidative damage
and eventually going gray so the main
cause of going gray is genetics but what
role can stress play after all Obama
didn't look like this when he showed up
at the White House so it's controversial
the role stress has in hair graying we
know that stress creates oxidative
damage in the body and it's been linked
to a lot of premature aging syndromes so
it's thought that the stress that stress
causes oxidative damage which may cause
damage to the melanocytes and may cause
us to grow gray earlier we know that
smokers tend to go gray more so than the
general population and again it's felt
that it's probably due to the oxidative
damage that smoke causes and how it
affects the human producing cells in the
hair I think eating a well-balanced diet
so you make sure that you don't develop
any nutritional deficiencies that's
another thing that can be done and
modulating your stress that's another
thing you have control over which over
time can cause oxidative damage and
again make you prone to potentially more
gray hair
[Music]